we're now
are we allowed to tell people that you
were in new york city are we back here
we are officially
are we allowed to tell people you're in
new york city no you're not allowed to i
want you to tell them i failed
don't tell anybody i was in new york
city nobody needed to know that you were
in italy
we're in south florida which only feels
like new york city everything everybody
has to do with this mango have you ever
had somebody walk up to you tiffany just
walked something yes
here's a mango yeah i'm like what do you
want to do five minutes before you so
tiffany if you're listening to this
thank you tiffany i appreciate the mango
to start off mangoes
yes we got valentine's day you know what
they say about mangoes though here we go
if your man ain't treating you right you
got to let that man go oh really
yeah all these
jokes i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell
you i'm gonna tell them mrs bisdock the
intriguing would
by the way somebody said they're running
late i got to give a shout out to face
comments fa
said pat forgot to fill his tank and is
waiting on triple a to fill it up the
other there we go
the other day i'm going to uh what do
you call it global what global uh
global what global entry that's what's
called global entry yeah yeah yes
i'm going to global entry in fort
lauderdale and i'm driving down
you got it now first of all the traffic
is
insane going over there and the bridge
at boca when it goes up at least it's
like two minutes
the bridge by the port that went up was
20 minutes it was a massive bridge
oh whatever it is yeah sort of
everglades right by the
way i'm waiting for this thing to go
finally i make it about my my car's at
zero at this point
i have no for about 15 minutes i've been
at zero miles
and i posted a picture and like it's
over this is going to be like my 50th
time i'm running out of yes
and i'm optimistic it's the attitude of
an optimist i think we're gonna make it
i think we got ten more miles on
empty i think we can pull this up and do
the impossible
and you know what the shelby said the
shelby said you're right
the moment i found this gas station
thank god for the chevron right off the
bridge i pulled up
the truck turns off turned off turned
off so that's what happens when you run
out again you ever had anybody
no i meant it here's what happens it
goes like this
it's kind of like choking chokes and i'm
like choke a little bit more
boom made it to the uh to the what do
you call it the pump
and uh i drove up to it with the cars
off filled up the tank it would only let
me fill up the tank because it's the big
shelby i was only
able to put a hundred dollars got back
in and took up and i went to the tsa pre
watch this i pull up
i'm 25 minutes late caroline calls to
tell him
he's late the lady gives her the biggest
attitude right
and i go in i don't have a mask on i'm
late i'm already like
you know i'm like oh my gosh strike one
strike two strike two and i've all you
know because i was with them for 10
years i missed one appointment and i
haven't had it for the last year so i've
just been using clear but again clearing
tsa is better than just having clear
pull up are you bet david yes
follow me like yes ma'am no i said ma'am
i'm so sorry i said
sorry you know how late you are i told
the lady that called me
don't even bother showing up you're
lucky we're meeting with you
i'm like i i totally apologize i was and
you know all the stories like a drill
instructor when you say
my cat my homework you know i'm telling
those stories but it's the real stories
i'm like i'm telling you
yeah i've heard all those excuses i'm
like fair enough so i sit down then the
next lady comes up she gives me another
attitude i'm like okay
how are you where are you from i'm from
everywhere oh yeah me too i've been
everywhere too
so tell me where every word is to you
it's like zero personality right
finally it gets done and i say ma'am
again i apologize about being late do
not be late five years from now when you
have your appointment i said i will see
you in five years five years you will
never see me in five years
because when you're coming i will never
be here i'm like okay
i don't know what it sounds like she's
happy to be there sounds like she's
happy to be there
i get in the car i'm leaving the next
day i'm interviewing michael malus
michael malus is uh what do you call it
he's the guy that
is the anarchist i don't know if you
heard of michael male as the anarchist
so we sit down we're debating he is a
full-on believes in anarchy he thinks
the
america is a better place without a
government and we're going through he
says he says have you ever seen how the
government treats you when it comes onto
customer service i said absolutely
yesterday
as a matter of fact an hour ago so you
were going just for a tsa appointment
not for your flight
no no i was just going for yesterday i
went for my flight yeah yeah days ago i
went for
you know for to getting so we'll see
what's going to happen hopefully
he was going in the second most valuable
number you have outside of your social
security number
is the number on the back of that global
entry card which is your
tsa pre number it's it is ridiculously
valuable
all right so let's get into it gang uh
super chat you already know the deal
when it comes on to super chat it's good
to be with you we got a lot of different
topics
to go through apparently ronaldo cost
coca-cola four billion dollars by simply
saying
coca-cola is not good to drink you gotta
drink water and he simply moved it just
really it just said agua we'll talk
about that
hunter biden is starting a career
full-time career as an artist
in his selling i've already purchased
multiple paintings
i can see there's a picture of a hunter
half a million a piece oh this says
artists this should say lobbyist i mean
yeah
let me just write that 500 biden gosh
artist to be
he's going to be an artist selling his
pieces to 500 000
which if you speak to the mob the mob
will tell you that's a business model
that is a business model which we'll get
into here in a minute that's exactly
right that's
when a small local dry cleaner does two
million dollars a year yeah the mob is
like they bring the clothes we take the
clothes
i asked all of you i asked all of you
what your favorite story was
of the day and we always obviously know
what adam's favorite story was
if you haven't heard folks catastrophic
the announcement was made yesterday by
ebay
ebay bans the sales of adult-only items
moving forward it's a
catastrophic struggle to get all my
stuff it was a tremendous
topic walked in today he's something i
actually was going to buy you a gift i
was going to get you a nice dildo but
you can't you can't sorry by the way
have you seen i owe you one now
but adam have you seen that guy that
goes around representing like he's the
media and he's interviewing guys and he
puts the deal down there
so tell me what do you think about what
trump said to the attorney god
guys
you know i follow worldstar because
every once in a while they posted some
of our short clips but every once in a
while
well you know they like the mob stuff
and the kobe stuff
and ric flair stuff but sometimes the
post they have is
just out of control i'll be in the bed
sometime like going through it just to
see what's going on
something pops up babe what are you
watching i'm like babe i promise you i'm
watching world star this is
oh you're watching world star
it's dildo interviews that's right it's
it's epic so
apparently they're not going to be able
to buy it on ebay anymore so it's going
to be a challenge so
morgan stanley chief to bankers if you
want new york city salary you need to be
in new york city that's going to be a
good one to get into
spotify clinch a 60 million deal with
alex cooper
for her uh color daddy podcast yanking
it away from
barstool and then dave portano yesterday
gave a shout out to
barclay if you ever want to be here we
would love to have you here can say
whatever the hell you want to say
because barclay yesterday announced the
fact that he's sick and tired of his job
because it's getting so uncomfortable
all they ever talk about off camera is
what you can say
and what you can't say and he says you
can't have fun with this anymore he says
i can't wait to retire
in two years barclays words we'll cover
that here in a minute as well
there you go big short investor michael
burris is back on twitter and warning of
the biggest market bubble in history
uh want to raise your kids with high
self-esteem we're going to talk about
that because the parenting experts
got something to say about that we'll
see what that is and then putin and
biden
say progress made in geneva but white
gulfs uh uh
on issues remain and donald trump visits
the border
before kamala harris and maybe we'll
cover lebron james's tweets about
injuries kai do we have those uh
uh the nancy to make the different logos
have we had that created okay good to go
so let's get right into michael bury how
about that i think michael bury's always
got a good thing to say that makes
people
think michael bury from big short what
page is it on page six let's get right
into it michael
bury big short all right let's pull up a
picture of the infamous michael bury
let's pull up his picture
gotta love this guy i love it i don't
know he's not a freak he's a regular
looking guy he's a regular looking guy
big short investor michael bury is back
on twitter and warning of the biggest
market bubble in history this is a
market insider story
suggesting that his concerns about
rampant speculation only grew during
this
10-week hiatus from twitter people
always ask me what is going on in the
markets the investor tweeted it is
simple
greatest speculative bubble of all time
in all things by two orders of magnitude
flying pigs 360. the hashtag was likely
referenced to a famous saying in
investing bulls make money
bears make money but pigs get
slaughtered berry has
repeatedly told investors and they're
being too greedy speculated wildly
speculating wildly shouldering too much
risk and chasing
unrealistic return returns the scion
asset
management chief the leaders tweeter
profile in april
after sounding alarm to tesla stock
which is short as well as gamestop
bitcoin dodge cone robinhood spax
inflation and border stock market
broader stock market so having said that
tom do you agree with what michael bury
is saying i mean this is not a guy that
just throws comments like that out there
right you know i think he's correct on a
couple axis and the question is going to
be
is which sectors pop right what
sectors i don't mean pop up which are
the the classic
pop of the bubble because there are
three factors right now
inflation is low but everybody's talking
about it going up you look at the number
of times it's mentioned in the media you
see all those charts people are talking
about inflation
interest rates are continued to be at
historic multi-year
lows and which makes debt cheap so
you've got three problems one i can get
all the capital i want
asset prices get inflated speculation
there we've already talked about people
taking uh the the millennials and the
z's
taking their uh their checks and open a
robin hood account rather than using it
for anything or paying their parents
rent
and so i i think he's right you've got
all these things that are driving up
speculation in the market
because there's so much capital out
there debt is ridiculously cheap
and you know i i think he's right the
question is going to be where does the
correction happen
does a correction happen in real estate
does a correction happen
in in energy you know where does the
correction happen
and i and right now you know my eyes are
on real estate because
what's happening in real estate there's
a really bad side of it that's happening
on rents and so i think the government's
got to
step up but i think he's right and so
what will be the pin that pops the
bubble
i don't know but i'll tell you i think
he's right
what do you mean by rent it's off by the
way if you've got what do you mean by
rents
well what's happening right now is if
you take you know you
you and me maybe we buy a small house
and we're to have it as a rental
right now if we pay 50 60
cash you know we probably keep the rent
at some
current market moderate but
right even at low interest rates with
debt we look back and we do the math on
it and the rent needs to be five six
seven percent higher
than it was a year ago because the
underlying asset
cost us more to buy and there's a
payback model we're not trying to gouge
renters
it's just the payback on it so i'm yeah
i'm looking at rents that are being
driven
by housing prices it's interesting that
you bring up
rents and real estate because if you
actually look at essentially what
is named here he's talking about tesla
stock gamestop which was we all
experienced the beginning of this year
and i interviewed the founder of wall
street bets who had very strong opinions
on everything that was going on with
gamestop
he names bitcoin he names obviously
dogecoin elon musk
a little uh friend right there robin
hood spax which we cover a lot
inflation which the fed just came out
and jerome powell had some
some words to share on inflation yeah
maybe i will maybe i won't
but i'm thinking about the broader stock
market so he names all these asset
classes that
you said could pop pop you know pop the
bubble i think it's just interesting
that you
he didn't name real estate but you
instinctively said well you know
maybe the real estate here because when
was where did michael bury make
his name for himself is when he
basically called the subprime mortgage
meltdown in 2008 he basically bet
against
america and if you ever saw the movie
with the big short with
right um brad pitt and uh yeah well
hollywood glamorized it but what he was
pointing out was there were bad
mortgages
in bonds and there is insurance on those
bonds and that combination
was the classic line that was in the big
short it says
if this the bond
was the what was it if the bond was the
you know was the match
then the insurance that was on the bond
that was 20 to one insurance
was the nuclear warhead and it was um
he was right no he was right he said
there were crap more than others
i'm curious if you're watching this
right now how many of you your rent has
increased i just looked at an article
right now rents for single family homes
just saw the largest gains in 15 years
this is a june 15 story which is two
days and when they say gain like a stock
what they're really saying is the rank
yeah so single family rents were up
5.3 percent year over year in april
rising from a 2.4
increase in april 5.3 rent went up that
means if i'm paying 2 000
a month now it's 2100 right if i'm
paying 3 000 that's
21 31.50 which you may say i don't think
that's not bigger
that's a single family that's another
two-thirds of a month that's that's that
may be not a lot to you
remember the guy that's making 50k is
going to see this
yeah that is the largest gain in nearly
15 years regionally by top
20 metropolitan markets rent gains were
highest in phoenix
and then a lower price of 70 percent
let's do super fast math on your example
path
you said for people listening 2 dollars
goes up five percent 100 bucks
that's 1200 a year so now you're on your
way to adding almost a 13 month to that
rent see that to the average person so
here's here's how that looks if you go
let's just say they increase
two thousand dollars fifty bucks says
200 bucks a year if a person is making
50 000
a year what's 1200 to them is that two
percent
that's two percent right 2.5 percent two
point
uh uh yeah two and a half percent of
their income
just went down that's pre-tax obviously
right that's pre-tax so even if i go
post-tax that let's just say that's a
four percent decrease
right i need a four percent range
imagine you go to your company and
you go to your company and they say this
year we're decreasing everybody's salary
by four percent
you may not feel it but you're gonna
feel it right because for that middle
america low-income family so
uh and then it's not only this gas goes
up everything is pretty much going up so
you're only seeing one
aspect of expense people are going to
see it on other places but
if you again if you're watching this and
your went went up i'm curious
has anybody felt it anywhere uk one
person said their rent went up 55
in uk mark sesh just says my buddies
rent from went from 1360
to 1700 in mesa arizona
yeah anyways we're gonna see what's
gonna stay the 17th that's a big number
it's time to find a new apartment
uh he's also in mesa arizona where
there's high demand back to
michael bury uh is this someone you
would want to get his perspective on
valuetainment is this someone that you
have spoken to michael brewery michael
berry doesn't want to do an interview
but if michael berry wants to do an
interview and we'll just do audio we
will all day have him on here
i would love to have him on no problem
uh because i think the guys
uh the guy's counsel and the way he sees
stuff
you're not necessarily a hundred percent
right
but you have to get perspective and to
me i think eventually
if you've been in this game for a while
like let me give you an example okay
sports can you see when it when when a
tide's turning when the team's about to
make a comeback
yeah literally last night philadelphia
versus atlanta that was ridiculous what
just happened was the philly was up 20
then they lose by seven
they're up 20 and 26 in the third
quarter with three minutes left
to the better the betters in las vegas
said there's a 99.7 percent chance
meltdown that philly's winning and they
lose it right but you
still notice them people are playing
sloppy people are getting nervous
they're missing free throws
michael burrie is that guy in
investments you have to listen to what
he has to say
it's that simple when he says it he's
got a point and i think if it does
happen
it is not going to be pretty here's the
only thing to be thinking about this is
just my thoughts on this on what to be
thinking about
is it fair to say every 10 years we have
a crash correct it's the first to say
every 10 years we have a crash
it's part of the cycle let's go back
last 10 years what was the biggest crash
in the last 10 years from 2011
to 2021 biggest crash obviously the
kovitz
okay perfect go from 2001 to 2011 the
biggest crash 2008
the great 2008 session 2007. yes go
1991 to 2001 the dot com
the dot com bubble right 99. go go 90
81 to 91 what 87
87 88 87.88 recession if we go
every decade there is a crash here's the
only differentiator here's the only
differentiator
so the only differentiator is if you
make 20-year runs you're not affected by
it
that's correct if you're making 20-year
investments
you're not affected by it you're only
affected by it
if your volatile game gamestop's gonna
make me a billionaire and i'm gonna make
my money off
dogecoin i'm only if you're playing that
speculative game
you many are gonna get their tails
handed to them but if you're playing the
long game
you may lose 30 percent of your
portfolio you may lose 20 percent of
your portfolio
long game you're going to see the
difference between day trading and
decade trading
right i mean day traders this is
literally goes back to his quote
where you know bulls make money bears
make money picks gets slaughtered
so if you're just all in on bitcoin all
in on dogecoin you think it's going to
the moon
you know there could be a crash landing
sometime soon yeah you know because you
which you like
like you say sorry to cut you off this
dog but you say about valuetainment i'm
on a 20-year run here
i'm doing this for 20 years so a video
you do today might pop it might get a
million views or
a video you do next week might crash but
you're in this for 20 years who gives a
like things will happen yeah you know
you you look at it this way
so 529s are out there which is a
savings exactly right so when bailey was
younger i left it in what's called
age and it was tiaa cref that was
managing it and because they were the
sponsor for california every state's got
a different financial provider that does
their 529.
so when bailey was there i had on age
age
synchronized risk which means when she's
in kindergarten the risk that they're
allowing to be
in the investments that are in there
automatically i don't make the decisions
i just say
i'll take the age it's kind of like a
target date fund
correct that's exactly right finance
yeah so what what happened was
you know she lost 30 of her poor little
when she was four years old probably how
old was she he's four years old
okay yeah now it's bounced back and
that's right now now it's back
and it's tripled since then bailey's a
millionaire no
no she's not a millionaire but you're
she's not gonna have student loans for
her bachelor's i'll tell you that's
great
great dad our grades are insane
go ahead tom and then what i did was i
flipped the switch
on age synchronized risk when she was a
freshman
because i was thinking about the traders
and maybe the synchronized risk with
their looking at the current market
and i moved it to you know you know
market index funds
and that which is another choice the age
synchronized risk has been
more volatile and i'm like wow their age
synchronized risk
these are people who are supposed to be
professionally managed target date funds
and even them pbd are you know what i'm
saying they're a little too
crazy but brooks fund i don't worry
about it because if it pops right now
it's like 2008 for bailey and then it's
going to be back but i think that
even i'm seeing so i'm seeing in wall
street
just in the 529s i think there's more
you know optimism and riskiness even at
a time where they're supposed to be
managing it according to
a target date fund and what's your
advice to the young people out there are
just starting to have kids and they're
basically setting up these 529 plans
look it's the taxes are going up
and so if income taxes are going up
there's more reason
to live moderately and to get 529
protection for some dollars for your kid
and take the long view take the long
view
yeah i mean listen here's the point
you're working day to day
you're going to get crushed you're
working long term you're going to be all
right
if you're going to be constantly
emotional buying selling buying selling
buying selling
you're going to take a hit but the
reality part of it is take a look at ken
golden
from golden auctions this is a
collectible card
auctions he just raised some money last
year do you know how much he sold last
month in cards
just last bloomberg contacted him to do
a story you know how much he saw last
month in collectible cards
what do you think he sold just last did
i tell you the number oh no what do you
think he sold
last month total collectible cards just
last month
auctions i'm gonna make a wild wild
guess just just remember like this guy
was doing a couple million dollars a
month
then he went to five million then he had
a record-breaking month he did 10
million what do you think he did last
month i'm going to say with all the
capital that's out there and everything
that's happened
did he touch a billion dollars a billion
dollars a month no that's aggressive
hearts
i would say 50 million 100 million 50
million last month
but you know what 50 million is up from
a million though guys you know what 50
million is 50 million is 51 million
cards it's 500 000
cards it's a thousand hundred thousand
dollar cards i don't think people write
like
50 million and you've got half 100 000
times 10
is a million times another 10 it's 10
million so 100
you're talking about the guy's selling
so much right now because people are
willing
to buy cards today they're not going
away right
but is that going to be the case if the
market tanks i don't know about that
long term are they still going to be
great investments non-duplicatable
assets will
always keep their value we need to add
non-duplicate all assets
assets that's it what's it like to have
a calculator
in your brain to like to have a
calculator you're literally like you
know
i messed one of them up when i said 50
million times 100 but you do have a
calculator up here i'm like let me bust
out my calculator
and get it you know you've got something
something going on up there
five hundred times one hundred thousand
dollar cards that's what i was gonna say
it's 500 100 000. those days to drive
you nuts
but you're on the big run yeah if you're
on the long you have to like listen
you're building a business you have a
bad day you you had a bad sale day but
you busted your tail
don't worry about it now here's the
thing if you had a bad sales day but you
didn't bust your tail
worry about it because habits are what
gets you destroyed long term
because you were listening you were
living easy and living assuming
isn't there a bigger story here a bigger
metaphor for
whether that's investing whether it's
relationships whether it's
health whether it's trading cards
whatever it is that
you're going to have good days and bad
days but overall if your perspective is
positive and you're here for the long
run
things are going to work out well
obviously if you work hard and you're
all right
sneezing on the truth if you if you do
your part yes
if you get emotional no if you're
constantly getting rattled
no if you can't say like what what'd you
say what happened
what did he say if you're constantly
what did the market do oh my gosh right
take it out that
this goes back to your stoicism that you
talked about last week well you know no
and also what he talked about a minute
ago about
what asset class are you playing in if
you're in a
if you're in a very risky sandbox that
doesn't have
natural scarcity for what's in there
non-duplicable assets with natural
scarcity
real estate on the beach scarcity
right so it may crash and everything but
that's the part that's
the scarce stuff that will be in demand
is going to come back first and so
but if you're out there i'll give you an
example if you're out there on gamestop
and you're
just living with the guys on reddit on
one stock there
talking about retail purchase of games
at a time when games are on the cloud
i think you're that is foolishly risky
because there's nothing to come back
when the party's over you know what i
will say if you're under
gold cards if you're under 25 and you're
doing it
go at it if you're under 25 you're doing
it go at it you're gonna learn something
you're gonna learn something listen i
was 25 and 49 thousand dollars in that
you know what i did one time let me tell
you one of the dumbest things i've ever
done in my life you ready is this the
vegas gambling story this is the dumbest
thing i did in my life i'm
25 years old 20 i'm 20
freddie chacon so this is what i'm 23
years old okay
uh uh i go to las vegas i'm trying to
say when i get my morgan stanley job i
got a 9-11 so it's a week
a week before i'm at morgan standing 9
10. so this is 9301 how old am i 9301 22
years old okay
i got an mbna credit credit card i go to
las vegas i said screw this
i want to make some money so my mbna
card allowed me to take out five
thousand dollars
cash so i take the whole five thousand
dollars uh oh i go at the table
paying 20 something and this is at a
time where
i'm sitting there i'm wearing this tank
top i'm just like
chiseled i'm in great shape and the the
greek goddess this is the greek god day
and the cashier says cashier mistaken
mistaking me for somebody else saying
are you here for the uh for the uh what
is it vivid convention i don't know what
it was are you here today
vienna convention are you here for the
fact i am i said i said
what do you mean it says are you here to
because are you one of the actors
are you right yeah that's nominated
actor of the year
so he brings the other guy yeah i know
you finished second so so
they're doing all this stuff we're
having a lot of fun together and then i
said guys
i'm gonna make 30 grand today period i
take the five thousand dollars ask me
how long it took me to lose the five
thousand dollars yeah what five minutes
thirty minutes
yeah gone by the way five thousand
dollars may not be a big deal to you
right now
it's a big deal you got a thousand
dollars in your bank account savings you
have
nothing else you don't have a four wink
you and you put 5000k
it's insane and you leave and you're
like at this point of the game i got
nothing left i got mad at age 22 22
years old and i'm going back and i'm
gonna go back into the army this is a
screwed i'm going back to in the army
on the drive back i get the call saying
dave kirby
has offered you a job at morgan stanley
dean witter i said you got to be kidding
me i
started up a week after i lost five
minutes and then lucky
let me tell you what's going on with the
call i kind of need a job yeah
it's like listen i honestly have many
options right now but you know what i
will take your job because i want it and
then backing out you're like no
i desperately need a job right now to
make up so the point is this look
when you're younger if you want to do
some stuff great don't make the big
stupid mistakes that you're going to pay
a price for
20 years you're going to make a mistake
you're going to pay price for the next
three to six months
whatever not the 20-year type of
mistakes but long-term if you're
investing long-term you don't have a lot
to worry about morgan stanley chief two
bankers well now speaking of morgan
stanley
morgan stanley chief two bankers if you
want new york city salary you need to be
in new york city this is a new york post
story
james gorman issued a stern warning to
his staff monday come back to the office
by labor day or
face a pay cut since the pandemic
pandemic first started the banking giant
permitted its 70 000 employees to work
from home
but with 70 of big apple adults
vaccinated and an
infection rate that's not even half a
percent gorman said it's time for
workers to get off their couches
and back to their desks the chief
executive also sent a
sobering message to workers who escaped
too far off
locate locales to write out the pandemic
if you want a new york city salary
you'll have to be
in the five boroughs to earn it if you
want to get paid new york rates
you're you work in new york none of this
i'm in colorado and work in new york and
i'm getting paid like i'm
sitting in new york city gorman barked a
similar move has been adopted by
facebook which told employees if they
want to keep working outside of san
francisco new york
they'll have to take a pick up what do
you think about this adam i mean i'm not
sure why he said if you're while you're
living in colorado because they're all
in miami
i you have no idea how many new york you
know
finance people are down in miami living
the time
of their life but you'd be amazed how
many are in colorado i'm sure there are
but
the i'm saying the people that i know
who are because they're skiing they're
they're they're all the birds yeah they
might be there for a week they're going
to aspen
i can't tell you how many people i know
from new york especially in the finance
world
you haven't you're okay there i'm i'm
good you keep going yeah mango
yeah but they're all in miami and
they're having the time
of their life they're the yeah they're
goldbergs
they're enough exactly they're they're
in an open state new york's
been on lockdown i think they just
opened up the earlier this week so to
california i was there
you were there yeah yeah i want to hear
about new york and they're just having a
great time they're making
however many hundred grand a year and
they're paying a fraction of what they
were paying in new york
and they're living their best lives and
you got this guy
james gorman no relation to james corden
who's basically saying
enough of this bs get your ass back into
the office you have until
september labor day so enjoy your
vacations enjoy your trip to aspen enjoy
colorado
enjoy south florida by the time school
starts right after labor day
your ass needs to be back in the office
the media doesn't get this
and no offense i even think you don't
get it the reason
the reason come at me bro hang on hang
on
here here comes a fast case study the
reason facebook was
mentioned to recruit engineers to leave
the university to leave mit or the
university of missouri or wherever it is
you graduated from
and come to those ridiculous back to
this again
housing and rent prices in the bay area
to compete
they had to pay certain salaries so if
you're in the bay area and the larger
companies will tell you
hey your salary baseline and this
sounded like a big number to people who
are listening
is a hundred thousand dollars but here
in the bay area you're going to get a
hundred and seventeen thousand
five hundred because it's a 17 000 cost
of living
adjustment that we give you for the bay
area and they tell you
now if you go to work in atlanta at our
regional office serving
ups and delta airlines and coca-cola on
behalf of
google you're back down to your baseline
of a hundred
they will tell you that and all they're
saying here he's saying look if you want
the new york salary
that we have to pay to to recruit the
best bankers because we're competing
with goldman we're competing with
everybody else how greedy of you the
media says
that just right how greedy is it how
greedy of you to take this no
shame on you what he's saying is he
didn't say you're going to get fired
he said if you want to go back and live
and work in colorado that's fine but i'm
going to baseline you for colorado costa
living
because to get you to come to new york
and work in new york is it fair i had to
come is it fair
it's damn fair you think it's fair adam
what they're doing yeah i do
i do as well i think it's very fair and
it's being spun like gorman's this ogre
that's
taken i didn't even read it i didn't
read it like he's being an or an
ogre i just said look if you're going to
want to get
look you get paid higher in new york
city or san francisco because the cost
of living is higher
the taxes are higher they get it the
salaries are higher and you're going to
be working longer hours especially if
you're working in finance in new york
city and wall street
what and by the way the facebook
facebook
do you know how many people that work
for facebook that are saying so okay
so if i want to stay here in atlanta i
want to stay here in
uh orlando i want to stay here in in
dallas
i don't get my uh san francisco wage
no you don't this well that's fine with
me because the cost of living is okay
here but i love
i like working for facebook and i got my
job people
get it especially when there's let me
let me tell you what just happened here
i was in uh san francisco a few days ago
okay
and we go for a walk we go to the
fisherman's uh uh
fisherman's wharf yeah mario has never
been to alcatraz before so we win it's
an awesome area that's a beautiful place
it's a beautiful place i know you was
there you were there last time you was
there you were there with your i was
there
you was there you told the story the
rock and we go and have the
the the clam chowder which is delicious
you know you have that whole clam
chowder did they put it in a bread bread
oh my i told them i said you got have
you ever had this they said no i said
you
caroline uh uh sam and mario you need to
try so they tried
so we walk up we go across the bridge we
go to the sushis but not the best
customer service but we go up and we
throw that in there for a little
sprinkle of coffee and we walk up all
the way to the end
this one place by the water and i go up
and there's a homeless man sitting there
and i said let me ask you are there
great white sharks out there
oh absolutely everywhere i said do
people swim here
everywhere i said so what do you think
about the city of san francisco
well it's not the same city it was
before but i still love this place but
keep in mind he's homeless he's homeless
okay he's homeless box everything next
to him yeah but i still love this place
what do you love about this place they
still take care of their people oh
interesting right right so yeah my new
syringes every monday
this guy is standing to my right and
he's listening to my 10-minute
conversation with this homeless man
he's in a beautiful bicycle but he's not
saying anything
so i walked this way and i said i said
what's yours this is i listened to the
whole conversation you had with him i
said what's your story he says i'm on
the complete opposite spectrum
i said really what's the spectrum he
said i own the biggest condo right here
on the water
i said really by the way just so you
know how much that is yeah you know how
much that is you're talking about 30
40 million dollar number it's not like
80. the biggest condo on the water and
fishermen
yeah 20 to 40 million bucks is what
you're paying just go look at
realtor.com right
his bike is a ten thousand dollar bike
everything he's got the leather jacket
on and he starts saying he says well
this is not the same city it was
two years ago yeah let alone i said why
he says
things have changed a lot it's changed a
lot during covet what they did is they
they they got i said you know i came
over here from morgan stanley training
uh to and i stayed at the mark hopkins
hotel he says well you wouldn't stay
there today i said why is that it says
because the mayor decided
to allow homeless people to stay at the
mark hopkins hotel
and they negotiated a rate of 250
dollars
and they got free parking that they gave
to the homeless people
and they the city the local people
living here
the taxpayers paid for it i said you're
kidding me it says no i said so how do
people respond to it
he said well first of all mark hopkins
hotel they're going to take the business
because it's
homeless they're they're not no one's
staying at their hotels
so they want to take some of the money
he says but it's not the same that was
their coveted relief plan i said i said
so how do you feel about the policies
here says well you know i understand
what they're trying to i said
he says you know what else is the
problem everybody that's getting out of
college that's coming here for a job
they want 180 to 200 a year starting
salary i said 180 to 200 college grads
he says yes because if you're not making
180 to 200 you can't survive in the city
so they're asking checks like that
numbers like that right and they're
getting paid because facebook and google
are competing
for engineering i said so tell me about
tell me about stores he says what stores
everything's shut down we don't have
stores i said why is it so
dead i don't see anybody here he says
there is no stores
everything's on lockdown stores are on
lockdown he's going through
the whole thing i said i got a question
for you said yes
i said you got a ten thousand dollar
bike you got an expensive jacket
you live on the condo on the water i
know how much that thing goes for
you look like you're a 100 million
dollar guy politically do you lean left
or right
pointed question to him yeah he says
well you know it's a little
probably i used to be a republican then
i became a democrat
and i'm an independent living over here
i said how do you think the policies
have done to the city
and he tried to defend the policies for
he tried it
so hard i said all of this
is not the people is not the president
it's not anything but local policies
that are no longer working
for people like you it's not working for
you anymore i said how much longer until
you leave this place
i don't know but i can tell you it's not
the city i fell in love with it's my
favorite city in the world and i came
here with the dream of
being able to live here for the rest of
my life but it's not the same it says
okay all right good talking i said great
we walked off they walked off
two different people one is loving the
policies the other one
is not loving the policies here's the
reality of it one's homeless one's worth
a hundred million which
one it's so crazy he said homeless
people are
coming here by the dr left and right
homeless people are coming to san
francisco because what do you mean
you're putting me at the mark hopkins
hotel for free
what other homeless person wouldn't come
here people would
volunteer to be homeless to stay at the
mark hopkins hotel yeah give me the name
of that hotel
that's exactly by the way mark hopkins
so tell us where clinton stay at it's
where
president stay out but it's not a
regular state it's a beautiful hotel you
stay there right so
this is a hotel for the homeless this is
a great uh we saw a wedding up at the
top floor it's called top of the mark
this is the story of what's going on to
a city like that
and people who are running now morgan
stanley dean what are they're starting
to realize
listen you don't want to be here working
with me no problem buddy but i'm not
paying you the same and i
100 support the decision and i'm not
firing you i'm just gonna pay you
well he can't fire it up no but i can't
fire them i mean if they fired him right
now you know what kind of a publicity
story they would have if they fired
their people
would you be all over the news would you
put a uh
you know a bow on this story because we
talked about morgan stanley we talked
about san francisco we talked about the
homeless
what's the overarching theme here where
you get where you going with all this
as you would say what's your point yeah
the point is policies
hurt great cities that's right so your
policies push people
out of a great state i'm on a flight
yesterday to uh
uh new york two days ago two to new york
i got back last night at midnight
guy sitting next to me is the insurance
guy of uh ernst young
and i said so what do you do for a
living he says i work at anderson young
i said what are you doing on sunrise i'm
their insurance guy
i said okay cool which office new york i
said really you're still in new york he
says oh now i'm in florida
and he's watching cnn it's so funny he's
watching cnn and i got my
espn i'm watching but he got cnn on he
go
so it's very easy to read people now
they see an msnbc right
so uh so i'm watching him and i said so
what are you gonna do with new york
you're gonna stay there he says oh no i
said why not he says look i've coveted
forced me out and i've been in florida
and i'm staying in florida it's gonna be
very hard to get me to go back to new
york
i said so how do you feel about the
policies in new york what do you think
about the policies
well you know i know what they're trying
to do you know it's great i think it's
they have to be taking care of their
people and all this stuff
i said well why don't you support those
policies and go live there and pay the
taxes
do you think he could support what
they're doing for people well you know
if i can find a way to pay less taxes
why wouldn't i to take care of my family
i said well you support those policies
don't you why do
i say so why don't you go fund those
policies and stay up there instead of
funding
no policies in florida because you're
not paying any taxes i see where you're
going with this but look i'm
i don't know what i'm going to do i'm
probably going to stay put in florida
again
bad policies drive out talent
that's not a lightweight guy that's a
heavyweight guy that's working
there's also ernst young one of the big
uh exactly
who's also being careful talking to
somebody that doesn't know and he's
looking at a house on his computer
that's a five million dollar house he's
shopping for
he's shopping for five million dollar
houses on his computer this is not a
lightweight guy you're talking about
right on what he's doing policies push
out good
talent you cannot keep bad policies that
detract
top talent and uh you know right now who
ends up looking bad right now
a guy who's running morgan stanley he's
looking like the guy that's the bad guy
you don't come back here is that how you
interpret that story i didn't
necessarily
look like the market is telling the
story
the media is telling the story right why
would you want your people to come back
let them be where they're at and get
paid and give them the same salary it's
not fair
well i'm sorry it is very every major
every major company in america has an hr
regional pay standard and and they're
they're not they're not slum lords
because they're competing for talent and
if you don't pay what you need to pay
for the talent in the various city the
other guy is going to get that talent
so people think oh they're just going to
do this or this no
no these guys will say if morgan says
hey we're cutting at 20
doing this morgan's going to lose the
great traders morgan's going to lose the
great people
they're going to go across the street
regional based
you know cost of living is real and you
have to pay that to get the great talent
and what pat's talking about i
completely agree is the local policies
have such unintended consequences
because what is the congressional
reelection
term right two years every two years
you're running
and it's always the short term
short-term policies short-term policies
give me the votes give me the votes
and the unintended consequences are huge
wooly brown when they had the council of
mayors in san francisco
kamala harris willie brown yeah two
decades ago
he was putting homeless on buses and
sending them to sacramento
because it would take him three days to
hitchhike back because they wanted all
the stuff they were getting from the
city for free
but he wanted him out of the visibility
when all america's mares were there
because he was polishing the image for
the short term
and so when you do this with the mark
hopkins you're probably reducing
homelessness in sacramento
because they're up there you know it
gets like 104 degrees here in the summer
yeah i know
i'm going to mark hopkins in san
francisco the homeless people know
what's going on
and and they're just moving to where the
the policy they think is going to help
them
well i mean listen elon musk just sold
his last house in california for 37.6
million dollars
acres it's 50 acres it's 16 000 square
feet it's a beautiful place yet
it's the last property here to sell
people are leaving
you can buy that and make it a boutique
hotel that's a huge property people
are leaving it's that simple that's
exactly what we are leaving
not because of culture not because of
bad industries not because of any of
that we got to tell him
he's screaming and hollering not because
of any of that
they're leaving because of bad policies
very simple
when my kids ask me a question they say
hey daddy who are we voting for
what do you think about this president
what do you think about that president
you know somebody in school you know
they're going to school and
somebody in school told me that trump is
for rich people and bidens for poor
people who should we be
uh for right he's explained he's asking
this question i'm having these types of
conversation my kids
it's interesting because you see the
teacher saying certain things and these
kids are coming home and they're sharing
it with you right
i said look kids it's not never the
individual forget about the individual i
don't look at the individual
i don't care if the individual does
whatever they want to do i don't you
don't care if they drink alcohol that's
not my business daddy that's their
business if they want to drink
but if you produce policies that produce
negative results that's when i become
concerned i said it's a policy war
it's nothing more than policies so when
people ask which president do you like
they'll say
i disagree with biden's policies
six-year-old dylan a seven-year-old
dylan says i don't agree with his policy
what percentage of america do you
actually think thinks that way
no man what are you talking about what
percentage
less than twenty percent yeah i would
say way less yeah i know
the only reason is because one in five
makes six figures in america today
so i i would say 20 i think it's a 20
number
who's actually sitting there thinking
about it who's actually sitting there
saying here's what we have to be
thinking about
anyways let's go into uh uh uh the next
story we have since we're talking about
parenting why don't we read this
parenting story page seven
donations kai i can't hear you kai i
cannot hear you turn on kai
donations take a quick look at your
donation what happened i haven't seen
super chat super chats there's some
people here
what's that the point um what super chat
made
this sergeant wilkins bring them down
guys bring them down bring them down
bring them down go ahead kai
uh no the super chat he says the real
issue is people coming from the places
like texas
florida and texas and will bring the
same mindset that brought the policies
that ruined their state
the one they're running to the mindset
needs to change sergeant wilkie you're
right i'm giving you 10 times what you
just gave right now on the super chat
he gave 20 bucks let's give him 200
let's give 200
to sergeant wilkie sergeant okay send us
a text at
four zero one 310-340-1132-310-3401
three two so we can send your 200 i 100
agree with
sergeant wilkie this is why states
change this is why states change
the biggest thing i say is the following
just look at policies man
i had a conversation yesterday with a
couple of my guys and here's what i said
this was tuesday our weekly dream team
call that we do
right after the uh podcast that we did
and here's what i said to them i said
how do you judge people actually think
about it we can hear you guys how do you
judge people
how do you judge people actually think
about how you judge somebody
if you were to say how you judge me how
i judge you
how do you judge tom how do you judge
harsh kai
[Laughter]
how do you judge david how do you judge
somebody wearing a sick
denim jacket you got it sam doesn't wear
his vest anymore i don't know what to do
how do you judge people used to be a
best guy it's summer good looking how do
you judge people i think
you know the old the old-fashioned
saying don't judge a book by its cover
but i think a lot of people
will well you know first impression is a
big deal
well you mean you're asking a rhetorical
question i hope you realize you
you that that judging people favors you
oh thanks because people look at you and
they say you know what this guy's got a
cool bike he's
riding his bike he's taking ubers he's
running he's getting a little bit i
think i think um
you know they say if you're if you go on
a date with somebody he likes cats
he likes cats for sure too if you're
going to date with somebody
how do they treat the the servers how do
they treat
perfect how you treat others let's
actually make a list by the way kai sam
uh
david i'm gonna ask all of you guys how
do you judge people folks i want you to
also participate in this i want you to
answer the question how do you judge
people okay your boss your cousin
you know a stranger a new person so
number one is
how you treat a stranger is that fair is
that what you just said okay you go to a
restaurant with a girl and you see how
you talk to the waiter how you treat
people
and the quote unquote below you or
serving you
how you treat people below you but my
mother would always say
i treat the janitor the same way i treat
the president of the company
that's like that's like your whole thing
what else how do you judge people how do
you judge
people how do you judge people guys this
is time let's judge people how do you
judge people by the way they dress
by the way they're dressed okay you
might look dressed up
by the shoes they wear okay by the way
they dress we all have to check our
shoes yeah i had to tell eric
uh our friends sergeant galera to throw
away his boat shoes that he's been
rocking i saw that what else
what other way how do you judge me this
is similar to what adam said but when
people can't do anything for you
i think that's an easy way to like okay
fair but what else how do you judge
people another one is
uh people how you judge someone that
might not like you but does that
necessarily affect how you judge them
okay a little technical but what else
like how do you look at somebody and say
that person's successful
how do you know i think um their
language the words that they use
i like the way that the way that they
speak are they are they talking
you know eloquently i listen well speak
up biz doctor what's up dog you're
judging me no
no i listen i listen to their language
how they say what they say because
you'll see a billionaire sitting next to
you that is not wearing the big watch
she's got a little apple watch
she's got things and he is not trying to
flash it what they say
but i like to hear how they talk what
are the words
who they hang out with what else i'm
just looking let me look at some of the
people i mean speaking of kai
what accent accent or the americans
somebody said once you find out where
they live
okay uh everybody's saying kai can you
speak up please character
k1 said skin color and race do you
actually judge people based on skin
color and race
do you think people judge people
basically based on skin color and race
that's what would be called president uh
prejudice
okay it's no it's it's uh it's sort of
baked in bias that people have from how
you grow up where that our good friend
you would probably appreciate this one
pat
and the bible how they smell a big deal
for you i i'm a big like the other day
david ordered a sandwich with
onions pat pat came out who ordered the
onions
you know what you know robert ordered
onions the other day he didn't want to
say anything i'm like what are you doing
oregon garden are you ordering onions
if you like onions you cannot work your
advice julia said character
mohammed azhar said how they talk by
actions
the way they look the words they use etc
etc
how about the way that their kids behave
okay now we're talking
the direction i'm going with it here's
how i judge people
okay it's very easy
for somebody to sell you on how amazing
they are we're all pros at it
everybody's great at selling you their
way of thinking everybody
is so great at selling you their way of
thinking they're fantastic at it
they can sell you their lifestyle they
can sell you their decisions
words are you know for example let me
give you stuff so you the reason why
i don't work that hard is because money
doesn't drive me i'm not i'm not driven
by money
the reason why you know i uh uh
don't like to work past five o'clock is
because family matters a lot to me
balance makes better people i want to
come home and i want to spend time with
my family and then they sit home for
four hours and watch tv and they're on
their phones for two hours and they call
that quality time right
we're selling ourselves amen on whatever
thing that we're doing right it's
selling we're selling okay
i judge you it's self-justification
wrapped in selling
i judge you based on your relationship
with your mom
when that day she dropped you off with
the bmw and we went in the car one to
wynwood
i judge you based on your relationship
with adrian
on how you guys are at that solo house
on how much that guy loves you
and you guys have traveled together my
best friend guys best friends no no like
well i mean i think both of you guys are
single i don't know the whole story
that guy is uh doing all right for
himself yeah
so then i i judge you based on keith
yeah
i judge you based on all of that my
network
your network who you are right and then
i judge you based on how you treat
people okay
i judge a successful person based on how
many people
around them are winning
if people around you are winning i judge
you and i say
check this guy's a winner here because
if you work with this guy guess what
you're going to win winning could be a
lot of different things winning could be
advancing
winning could be a lifestyle winning
could be monetary
winning could be the way the person
improves as an individual
communicates before they came here how
they talk now winning could be
how that person processes issues winning
could be how that person leads winning
could be many different ways if i watch
the people around you winning i say
you're somebody worth following right
okay how do you judge policies
this whole thing is about policies right
how do you judge a good policy
based on the results how many people are
winning it's not about so if you think
about
how many politicians sell how amazing
their policy is
i don't give a how great you are at
selling how amazing
your policy is what i care about is the
results
of your policies and the policies of new
york
and california are catastrophic
the the results of the policies
of whatever the mayor of san francisco
did is catastrophic
the results i'm in new york walking
driving my driver's taking me places
boris i had a chance to meet boris good
guy by the way very good conversation we
had with boris
until i realized who boris was we're
driving around
boris is taking me places and we spent a
good uh the entire day he was with us
right
and i said so tell me what do you what
what's happening with new york he says
it's not the same anymore so what do you
mean it's not the same
this is yesterday so what do you mean
it's not the same anymore he says people
have left
i said do you feel it he says do i feel
it what do you mean do i feel it
500 000 people left yes i feel it how do
you feel it
business customers
traffic is less i feel everything yep
that people have left
he said i said so what are you going to
do long term so i don't know guy's got
three kids i think he's got three kids
right
i don't know what i'm going to be doing
right smart intelligent guy when i'm
talking to him
tommy you know so what do you think my
sister so why do you think some of the
people who sell their policies he's
telling me this
he says i watch jorge ramos i watch
univision i watch all this stuff
we feel like the policies are good i
said no it's not the policies that are
good man if they were so good the
results would be so good
so the way you judge a politician is not
by how they talk
unfortunately the lower level stuff is
that because
the lower level of judging somebody i'll
never forget fernando lasso was one of
my groomsmen at my wedding
first day i started working at hollywood
valleys el centro
i walk in i'm like you know i walk in on
this you know
guy you know he's like hey what's up how
you guys doing how's everybody that i'm
just talking to everybody
this is pat when you first walked in i
said this has got to be the cockiest guy
i've ever met in my life he says i
didn't like you
i didn't like the way you looked i
didn't like the way you walked around
like you owned this place something
i'm like i he says six months later
you're my best friend of my life
we became best friends for another last
night the relate the stuff we did
together was a different story
sometimes people look at somebody and
they say this guy looks like he's rough
around the edges this guy looks like
he's this they judge but sometimes it's
the other way around you look at
somebody and say wow he's so presentable
yeah he's so you know he looks like he's
got his stuff together but then deep
down inside
there is no substance substance to me is
results and
results to me is policies and policies
that produce the right kind of results
check mark good for you keep at it so
we can say all we want about how amazing
and how noble some of these politicians
are just go look at their cities that's
the best way to judge them to see how
great of a job they did for their what
do they call it constituents is that
what they call it yep that's exactly the
thing
i work for my constituents why don't you
clean that place up because your
constituents are kind of
not too happy with you right now but the
ones that are voting for you is the
programs you keep giving them for free
and people are paying a price for it
those who are creating jobs for you to
be able to have tax money to come up
with the social programs
you're pissing them off you may want to
be careful with that part right there
anyways okay all right so let's continue
this has nothing to do with how to raise
your kids though
we still haven't gone to it i paid seven
let me go to page seven uh raise no i
was going there and i got interrupted
here
and i changed subjects i think it was
well worth it okay
so tried it back to politics one to race
kids with high self-esteem you just
pointed me in the interruption thing
of course i did i'm judging you the
entire time out of fact you know what
this is yours go ahead
so i'm supposed to eat the mangoes
tiffany i just gave it to tom it's it's
we're passing it now past pastor
you know just in case somebody felt
special from the mango
yeah everybody got a mango around here
no way everybody gotta make it i don't
like that i wanted to be the only person
yeah no no no no no no so then the
question becomes is this the biggest
bengal
maybe maybe maybe she's saving the big
pizza
you saved a big piece of chicken for
daddy when he gets home right cmbc story
cnbc story want to raise the
kids with high self-esteem a parenting
expert on the power of teaching your
kids repetition and ritual
the first few years of parenthood is a
huge adjustment especially if you're a
working parent
all of a sudden your baby is walking and
talking they turn
then they turn three and demanding to
know why you have to leave them to go to
work
whatever your work schedule these
mornings those mornings evenings
weekends can feel
very short and you want to make them
enjoyable and high impact and building
your kids confidence and self-esteem the
key technique to getting there
is through teaching repetition and
ritual if your son knows you'll pick him
up and hug him in the same way when you
came through the door
each evening he'll look forward to it
and he'll be thrilled when it happens
sing that favorite song
together each day on the way home from
daycare begin each saturday morning with
breakfast at the same time tuck him into
bed in a consistent way each night for
you repetition is dog but for children
especially toddlers it's wonderful and
reassuring the world is a brand new and
complex place
and when they see patterns in in it or
accurately spot what's coming next
it gives them a sense of security
mastery and delight
tom uh i i think there's some truth in
this but i think it was a puff piece by
cnbc
but i will say this you know what you do
when you bring consistency to a
two-year-old
they sleep through the night and
everybody's happy yeah so
when you you put them to bed at the same
time and put them through a ritual
they yeah they the kid has a more
consistent pattern you don't want the
kid waking up middle of night crawling
in the bed
with the toy saying it's time to play
it's no it's not it's 4 am leave this
alone
the obviously that's never happened to
you oh it's happened to everybody where
your kids had a sink you're at a
you know you go out of town to a wedding
and so you're you're up late till 10
o'clock and then the kids had a sink
and then the next two days the kids
literally out of sync they're tired
they're grumpy it's hard to get them up
and so when you take the routine of it i
think routine for kids is good
it gets sleep patterns and activity
patterns
big time but i'll tell you i'll tell you
something else there is something here
in consistency and trust because the
kids want to trust in something
right it is a tough world out there and
kids feel stressed in certain ways too
but when they know that you're going to
be there
and they can count on that that is a
huge part
of the parental child love i can count
on you
it also gives you permission and it
gives you the opening
to put the disciplines around them the
disciplines of structure behavior of
time and things like that i'll tell you
if you travel with tom here's what
happens tom every morning
calls his daughters no matter where he
is in the world okay and every night
before he goes to sleep tom calls his
daughters and they pray together
no matter when it is by the way i've
never seen tom forget those two things
when i tell you never i mean i've never
ever
ever we could be at a party tom will
step out make the call talk to his girls
and he come back into the party no one
knows what happened
but i'll see tom on the fun of my kind
of what tom's don't leave him alone
he'll be back in 20 minutes
does this thing comes back when i tell
you consistently
i mean consistently his daughter is
probably going to end up going to penn
okay if not michigan but she's going to
get to choose where she wants to go her
his oldest bailey who responded the
other day to scott galloway's article in
a way that
adults wouldn't respond to what uh
bailey said and then brooke
is probably going to be an mit student
if she wanted to she can go anywhere
a lot of it is how he and kim raise
their kids with the rituals adam
yourself
you hear this commentary do you have any
any thoughts this makes me think a
couple of things you brought up you know
the whole work life balance i know you
were kind of mocking that a little bit
but essentially what i i would take from
that is rather than you having to get
home at 5 30 and then
we kind of mockingly said yeah you're
spending two hours on the phone and
you're bs'ing
it seems like it's more important to
have one hour of quality time where you
guys can
you know throw the baseball or you know
do you know whatever you do with your
daughter play dress up whatever the hell
it is that is
special yeah yeah yeah i know you put on
some some pink outfits and you put on a
crown
a lot of i've seen you do that yes with
santa but the point is it comes down to
quality time and repetition
and uh and just being there for your kid
like i gotta tell you
every time i get out of here at eight
o'clock i'm home right i'm home by 8 15.
my cats are getting that good quality
time y'all all right they get a good
hour of what
how's your day parents you are it's it's
it's repetition
you know and every weekend so every
weekend they know
daddy's gone for the weekend he's in
miami he's doing what he's doing but
he'll be back sunday night chat
whispering he'll be back
yeah do you do you speak to them no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no it's how you do you do
affirmations with them
affirmation is my own they love you
kitty cat you know who love do you say
stuff to them or no do you talk to them
at all or no
i talk to jimbo yeah i see you have a
great relationship
as much as you we make fun of my cats
you got two dogs that are your
everything oh my gosh
i'm not listen if i can't my way out of
10 cats at the house i love cats i'm not
a
i'm part of the community of cat lovers
man i will say for those who are dog
guys cat guys
i've seen some cats before that suck i
would never raise my cats to be sucky
like this is it based on the parent or
based on the 100
based on the parent and if you're gonna
get a cat there you go get two cats
because they're playing all day
joking around so we left out fighting
yes right nothing's worse than one solo
so we have to go back
20 minutes now we have to add to it how
do you judge people by
the behavior of their cats yeah that's a
very good point that's philosophical do
they have good cats
that's something like frederick are they
are they arrogant
i don't care about you and i'm just
gonna sit over here no i would never
raise cats like that you know what i'm
talking about
adam would slap him around oh yeah snap
out of it don't be cocky with me
no exactly hey can you pull up that
story with barclay can you pull up that
story with barkley
here we go i just love barkley saying
this by the way love hearing about
barclay
charles barkley to leave the inside the
nba blames canceled culture
we can't even have fun anymore go up a
little bit to read what he says
baseball legend charles boxing decade
long tienes and seven empty and he
blames cancer cutting appearance on
washington uh
radio uh sports radio station wjfk
106.7 the fan mr barkley slammed as
jackasses the social justice warriors
who
launched online attacks and even
criticized his bosses
and co-hosts on tnt it's gotten so out
of right out of hand right now
i couldn't imagine having to watch
myself you can't even have fun nowadays
without these jackasses trying to get
you canceled
and things like that he continues to say
he's 58 years old right and he says
i'm just having fun talking about sports
i'm trying to hang hang on for another
couple years until i'm 60 and then they
can kiss my ass i'm only working until
60.
i already told them that we can't even
have fun anymore we have had fun all
these years
and all of a sudden in the last year and
a half everybody is trying to get
everybody fired it really sucks can you
imagine
barkley talking about this and then
we're going to talk about the scenes yo
man
be careful going in that direction all
we ever talk about behind the scenes is
yo man be careful going in that
direction we can't have fun anymore
we've had fun all these years and all of
a sudden the last year now
same thing here so barkley i
don't know how many emmys has won i
think it's eight i don't know the number
how many emmys has barkley won can you
pull it up
i think he's won eight nine he's won a
bunch of emmys right
here's a guy that's won a bunch of emmys
he's loved admired probably the best guy
to listen to entertaining as hell
he keeps that show together if you think
about it he has one foreign
shaq says the face of this show is
charles barkley
shaq he said the face of this who also
together
is charles barkley right to say
something like this how much credence do
you give to what he says right there tom
i give a lot of credence and i'll tell
you why um i
love barkley you and i had the privilege
of um in dallas going to see him speak
one time
yes yep at a um you know a
college function that was there and
what's really interesting
is i think was about six weeks ago
barkley
on camera on stage during the show said
you know what
i'm getting tired of what these
politicians are telling people to
believe
because i think black most black people
most white people
most hispanic people are all good people
they're all good folks
and they're getting tied up into this
thing you remember that he gave that
little speech
and i thought that was so pure and so
necessary for him to say you know what
the people i see i think everybody of
all colors is basically good and they're
getting revved up by outside forces
do we need have things in america that
need to be addressed yes
do we have things need to be changed yes
do we have
historical things that have kind of
followed us around that we have a chance
to get a new generation thinking
differently
yes but right now the majority of people
are good people as we work through all
those things
but they're getting revved up by the
government that wants power and pitted
against each other
and he's talking here these jackasses
are just trying to get you fired
it's a technique of lobbying now to get
someone fired for having anything other
than no opinion
i think it's terrible what's going on
with charles but i think he uh
to tom's point i do agree with him here
look charles barkley
is a personality uh even when he was
playing in the nba he had a
larger-than-life personality
he went against the grain he said i'm
not a role model remember that famous
commercial
tell your kids not to listen to me who
says that what adult says that
so this guy's been cancelable before
cancel culture was a thing
but he's maintained it for the last 30
plus years i think something that is
resonating
i mean what sign what side politically
do you think charles barkley leans
center center what he's probably center
period center
okay well i think he's more center left
i mean he supported doug jones in
alabama
he supports more democrats than he does
republicans sure that's for sure
okay which way do you think bill maher
leans politically as an example center
left
center left okay left so you have
there's a theme here going on here even
me for example
charles barkley center left uh bill
maher
a little more left but it seems like
he's coming center
me a little more left especially
socially fiscally a little more right
coming a little more center and what's
the common theme we're all basically
seeing
what's happening with this wokeness and
this cancel culture and we're like this
is ridiculous
being woke you know a few years ago
actually was a good thing
meaning i'm aware of what the hell's
going on i see what's going on i have an
opinion
i'm not just sleepwalking through life
now woke has a khan
has done a complete 180 and if you're
woke that just means you're part of this
you're cancelled you cancel culture aunt
jemima you're done
redskins you're done you did this 20
years ago you're done
canceled fired you're done and that's a
very slippery slope and i think that's
exactly what charles barkley is talking
about here
is that if anything you say or anything
you do
is automatically cancelable and a
cancelable offense
that's not america anymore you know you
know what uh uh
uh eisenhower said in his farewell
speech
when he was uh coming out do you know
what he said do you know do you know
what direction i'm going with this guy
or no what's this thing
okay he said in his speech he says
beware of the military industrial
complex
okay and what he said about this is the
following he says
if if you use the word communism to try
to cancel
anybody be very careful with that just
because somebody uses the word communism
you don't cancel them
this started off with them right
hey i have 200 and something people kind
of like adam schiff saying i have proof
here that the trump was colluding with
russia i have proof
here right and there's been no proof
that he ever brought up
and uh so this cancel culture thing
is something you have to be very very
careful with
you know lincoln has a quote i'll look
for to read it to you
and he says the same exact thing it is a
like he was talking about prohibition
where people are using prohibition to be
able to arrest anybody
i mean if you're going back and you
think about these laws that we came up
with right you go back and think about
the the mccarthyism was what if your
communist
anybody that's your friend i can come
after them as well and tape them right
very differently then that goes to rico
what did rico allow you to do and in
in ricochet racketeering but what rico
allowed you to do is for if he's even
hanging out with you i can record his
house without even getting permission
slippery slope and enrico led to omnibus
and omnibus led to patriot act
it's more control control control
control control right okay
today if you think about
who's doing most of the silencing which
side of the aisle is it today
yeah it's that will definitely be the
left at this it's the left especially at
universities is that's like the big
knock away number one is universities
yeah number two is social media number
three is you know i mean i can go on and
on you can't
people people don't feel everybody who
said anything about the virus being
man-made got canceled until jon stewart
said it on stephen colbert
yeah there's just he said it on stephen
colbert that video went viral
why does he go viral and stephen colbert
doesn't get cancelled
but everybody else that talked about it
the last 12 months they got cancelled
you know how many videos were being
canceled because just because we had a
person that said
say what they said so the the the
there's a reason for that
which is what i think a lot of people
are willing to listen to people that are
on their team before they're willing to
listen to someone on the other team
telling them what's right or wrong so if
john stewart who's traditionally
a liberal no one on the right is going
to listen to him as an example
right you're it's a lot of echo chambers
jon stewart i disagree i think he's what
do you mean he's a liberal
senator always listen to john stewart
you're one of the few no
many many people maybe the point that
i'm getting here is the macro
respectively i think john is reasonable
it's a lot easier
i think he's smarter if you're i'll just
be very clear here it's a lot easier if
you're a democrat
yeah to convince other democrats hey
guys your way
of thinking is a little wrong you need
to figure this out versus
a ted cruz trying to convince democrats
to think a certain way versus a democrat
an adam schiff character or a stephen
colbert speaking to republicans trying
to convince them versus
donald trump saying hey guys you got to
change up how you're thinking i think
the point that i'm getting at is that
you're willing to listen to someone
that's on your team before
someone that's not on your team so it
takes someone like a jon stewart
to wake up the the left if you will
as to maybe the virus i agree with that
i think meaning
it takes somebody from your own side to
wake you up yeah
yeah but i also think the reason why a
lot of people were silenced the last 12
months is not because it's an opposing
idea it just doesn't fit the narrative
so if you're trying to drive a narrative
narrative narrative narrative narrative
you have to silence anybody that doesn't
fit the narrative and that's what
happened the last 12 months
okay and so and now and they're they're
sitting there saying well you know
yeah you're right it could be man-made
we don't know who says it can't be
man-made not
so it's a very very slippery slope uh to
go in a direction like that
and uh i i applaud listen i said this
yesterday
i said walking on eggshells
and cancel culture it always eliminates
the most talented
entertaining people barclay is the most
talented entertaining person he steps
away i agree
kevin hart was supposed to host the damn
oscars
he's the most entertaining funniest guy
at the time the guys were getting box
office he was making records after
records after record
to the point where he tweeted something
the other i sent him a message he says
much love and i appreciate you
you know it's just congrats on
announcing we're going back and forth
texting each other
there are certain people that you lose
like we want the ricky gervais we want
to build birds we want the chappelles we
want the
kevin harts we want the barclays but no
they offended somebody
they offended somebody you got to be
very careful because you can't say that
god forbid
you offend somebody and then nicole
nickelodeon the other they post a
offended video on the left nickelodeon
post a video the other day trying to
please the transgender community you saw
the numbers with nickelodeon
did you see what happened when the
collodion's number after that ad that
went up sure it plummeted
oh it's not even plummeted it's
catastrophic
catastrophic because transgender is not
a democratic thing
democrats some democrats are sitting
behind closers like listen i'm not
i'm not like why are you putting that in
my kid's face
if you support it support it but this is
nickelodeon what are we doing here oh to
try to please a small percent what
percentage of america is transgender
like one percent it's not even one
percent no no it's probably one percent
of one percent
so to try to please the one percent of
one percent
but you throw the other 44 under the bus
and you lose that audience it's not only
it just doesn't make sense it's not even
a good business model
to do that there's there's nothing about
it that makes any sense
did you did you see that video uh of
it was a family yeah asking hey would
you take a picture of us
uh and they give a camera to uh just a
random guy and it's like a
family of five and he goes okay say
cheese and then
excuse me i'm actually a vegan i don't i
don't do cheese
okay so we won't say cheese all right
everybody
smile well you know i'm actually
depressed right now so i'm not willing
to smile
and basically every family member has an
excuse
as why they couldn't take the picture
and it just started with say cheating
and this poor guy is like yeah he's like
dude
do you want me to take a bathroom i'm
out so i'm sorry here's your camera back
yeah yeah i mean it's listen more power
to uh barkley in two years we're gonna
lose him enjoy the guy for two years
well until you it's fair to say chuck i
know you're a big fan of the the podcast
you have a seat here to my right tom
will have to send this one out
but anytime that charles barkley wants
to come on we'll we'll have to bring him
on i'm a guest here and i appreciate it
but i would love to sit back and watch
sir charles on this
program all right hey i think it's good
we
go a little bit more of a creative side
on the stories let's talk about hunter
biden
is starting a full-time career as an
artist and is selling his work for up to
five hundred thousand dollars please go
to page three mr ellsworth
why would you discuss this story some
his life is something like
modern art yep hunter biden has embarked
on a full-time career as an artist and
some of his paintings can cause six
figures in a statement his dealer george
berge
uh told insider it is an honor that i'm
able to represent hunter biden he's a
wonderfully gifted talent and fine
artist he has garnered a following of
collectors who appreciate
and see the intrinsic value of his work
biden 51 years old has been painting
since he was a young child and he told
arnett that he's
never had any formal training in his new
los angeles home biden reportedly
converted a three-car garage into an art
studio that includes a brick floor
and skylight prices for his artwork
range from 75 000
uh for work on paper to 500 000 for
large
scale paintings who actually
fully believes this adam are you
you know what do you think about this
story here well i've already bought
three pieces
so it's uh i think he's a talented
artist i think hunter biden
is uh is the next picasso clearly it's
uh that's what's going on well
you know i think something for the first
thing that came to mind
when i heard he's becoming an artist
it's that he's getting in on this nft
craze
is that everyone out there is an artist
and they're doing nfts now
and half the people are like what the
hell's an nft and other half of the
people are basically saying it's the
next big thing
um but the next thing that i'm thinking
about that other than the nft
is i actually think that hunter biden
deserves to be on a list
that we have a running list going on
right now and that list that we've been
talking about for a few weeks now is
who are the biggest trolls out there we
put takashi 69
we put jake paul up there i think hunter
biden
smoking crack doing whatever business
he's doing
whether it's shady or undisclosed
whether whatever this artwork is going
on
i think he's actually just a troll and
he the media is obsessed with him
and uh i think he's doing a good job of
trolling however
i don't know where where this artwork is
going i'm sure you have a very different
perspective on his artwork
look this there's narratives have
purposes right
and there is a media narrative that is
trying to
um clean up the hunter biden image
in time for the midterm elections and
that's the narrative the narrative
around hunter biden
is the liberal side of the media the
mainstream media are trying to
you know adjust the image of hunter
biden
in time for the midterms that's all
that's going on here
that's the narrative so little things
like this
somebody's sitting around and says okay
this way the story will be
i love this sentence here he has
garnered a following of collectors who
appreciate and see the value of his work
from china from brazil i'll change it
this way
from mexico he's garnered a following
arabia
hang on he's garnered a following of
donors who appreciate the value of
getting close to his father
yeah i changed two words in a sentence i
mean come on
i i think this is a narrative this is a
puff piece that's been put together
to help adjust his image in the face
of the facts that he himself is just
dumped in the lab i remember
i remember jerry tarkanian being
interviewed and saying
the shark he says your players get paid
unlv you know the old larry johnson
stacey augment
uh who was the plastic man anthony and
all those guys i see augmented yeah
that's right left-handed guy greg
anthony gregory great team unlv running
anthony once went up against was it
jordan he tried to fight or kobe he went
up against one of those two guys greg
anthony they went into it
they got into it i think it was uh
anyways so jerry tarkinis being
interviewed and they said listen you're
paying your players
i'm not paying my places we followed the
guidelines of the ncaa very strictly
they said voices what do you mean he
says
how do you guys have big jewelry listen
we follow the guidelines
very strictly period and and the
reporter keeps going but you keep paying
your places i'm not paying the players
so then
i'm obviously i have a lot of friends in
vegas and i've interviewed a lot of
random people who know a lot of people
in vegas who
bet and you know the unwv was known for
losing
that what do you call it the uh whatever
the spread was okay
they're favored by six somehow they lose
by five turnover at the end of the game
they were
great at dealing with donna they
controlled all of it right so
he said look it was a very simple
business model he says
they would go and have a job as a valet
for 30 minutes or whatever it was and
they would say stand over there
work valet and when the red car comes
you only get to value that red car
so they would go valet the red car that
would park in the tip would be a hundred
thousand dollar tip
he followed the guidelines strictly
yeah i'm just doing my make i make five
bucks an hour but i make a hundred
thousand tips right i get to keep the
car
yeah he seemed like a nice young man
took good care of my car
that's it how i tell me it's my business
people people tip like that every day go
ahead
imagine the one day somebody else goes
and gets the car
by accident oh my but they're gonna know
who tells you
because you would know grandmama if you
see lj you would know this guy's a
monster right is who he was anyways one
of the players on that team is a barber
now and he's at the barber at the same
place i go to
and he's got some crazy he was on the
unlv
running 911 yeah he's a barber now and
he has
some he says listen as crazy as you
think it was it was a hundred times
worse wow he says he says the kind of
stuff that we were doing was ridiculous
he says i've never partied like that in
my life
he says it was crazy to think things
were being done to us
we were doing stuff that shouldn't be
you're the best basketball team in the
country
in college nba team and you're the best
and you're the biggest
nba team and you're in college right so
what's the moral this is exactly time
there's a moral discipline
the moral of the story is he's not
breaking any laws okay
which means if let's go both ways
let's go both right brain and left brain
okay
right brain says what what an incredible
artist
good for him leave him alone let him be
creative
you know his mind goes places and he
wants to put art he's creative you know
creative people when you smoke crack
your mind will go to different places
and then you can i i had a friend of
mine that would do shrooms all the time
and i used to love having dinner with
them because i would say did you see
that unicorn and he would say no
i would walk them outside look up
and i would sing in the background
never-ending story you
remember the movie i don't know what
grade one right he says man i missed the
unicorn i said no you got to see the
other one the flying dog the flying dog
right there and he would buy it
naive guy innocent i think that you're
actually seeing it because he took that
many mushrooms he was
that and we would go he was on acid
maybe not mushrooms he was it was both
of them
he would be the one that would
discriminate some mushrooms of lsd
shakers shakers we would go there with
him and my friend armin who's no longer
with us
anyways so look if hunter wants to be
creative more power to him if he wants
to be creative you know you know
sometimes when you age
president bush started doing artwork
what he's doing money laundry come on
man he's just doing artwork right
right but on the other side is let's
just say this is a play to play type of
a model
okay let's say he is doing art where
people from other countries who are
you know powerful people from saudi
arabia all of a sudden buys one of his
art pieces for seven million dollars
if that happens yeah and you don't
speculate
you are the most naive person and
totally agree with you but i tell you if
it's selling for 50 grand 75 000 if
their money laundering at that price
that's nothing no one's doing seventy
five thousand dollar money laundering
type of deal let me let me ask you guys
i knew this uh joe when i selected him i
i knew this was gonna be a problem i'll
just
find it amazing that we got through
eight years of this before it blew up
and you know how hard it was to keep a
lid on this i should have got a
another nobel prize for just keeping a
lid on this one
was that obama clinton or obama
you know it's a problem if you don't
know that no that was
clinton would be i don't really
understand this i think this
this article that was obama's you do a
way better clinton than obama you want
to give it another crack are you good
i i didn't let my brother get anywhere
near stuff like this remember
you're good on clever roger clinton not
obama i don't know
can you do obama or no change
does anyone have change for a dollar no
you sound like jerry scientific yeah
okay i can't
what's the deal
okay what's the deal okay
but okay you bring up actually a good
point here with your friend
um roger clinton that was clinton's
brother by the way a plus on your
clinton
c-minus on obama but you're keep
practicing biz doc don't stop
i guess my bigger question i guess my
bigger question here is
how much sway good or bad
do the president's kids or family
members
actually have on the polls or votes
meaning the first lady melania yeah uh
dr
jill biden michelle they've got some
sway that's the first lady like they're
in but you know i don't know how much
pull the trump kids had i don't know how
much pull hunter biden has
or sasha and malia or roger clinton
i feel like all right where are we going
what's next i feel i feel like every
um how much president how much pull do
you have when you go to body bodega
i don't mean pull i mean like in terms
of voting
what are you talking about good i'm good
if you go to bodega what happens
things are good you're treated you're
not even keith's son you're a friend yes
you're not anything in that it's not
like you own a part of it right this is
their son
we i mean he's like i'm a hunter biden
bro
you want to get to my dad i'm a contact
away i don't mean it like that
clearly i mean in terms of 10
you're right no like roger clinton did
pull
votes yeah i didn't no i didn't say i
said polls not pull
i got it clearly you're a pull i'm i'm
i'm chelsea clinton i'm a clinton
like slynn's daughter i'm i i'm donald
trump jr yeah you want to get to the
the president yeah i don't think i mean
i'm turns into the in the actual
votes people say you know i was a
clinton guy but i'm really not a fan i
think america rolls their eyes
america rolls their eyes at this stuff i
remember that's my point i remember
um jimmy carter had a brother billy
and he was when you do a jimmy carter no
and he was he was a raging raging
alcoholic
with issues billy was yeah and jimmy
carter made no
apologies for him he says look he needs
he's he needs to get his life together
like anybody else does
he gets off the airplane i think it was
air force one he gets off the airplane
on the tarmac
and you know there's a bathroom on the
plane but apparently he just walked
around behind a couple of those enormous
wheels
and took a leak on the tarmac and you
can go look it up that's some gangster
right there
yeah and you know and president united
states is
but his name was billy and so some
company
like played into his alcoholism and he
had a brand of beer it's called billy
beer
i have i have you know
uh you know back in the day had a friend
that used to collect beer
cans you know like trading cards like
rare beer cans and things like this
but it was um anyway billy beer man
so i i think i think by and large the
american population rolls their eyes
at it until it crosses over and
jared jared kushner crossed over he's
doing things in politics
so now this really matters and we get
big opinions on it hunter biden was
doing things on international stage
now we wake up and we don't let him get
by with it
so but i think he's right it's billy
brother billy beer
yeah billy beer yeah and take a look at
him close do you see the family
resemblance from a younger jimmy carter
i see it and it's just like and you can
also look on there
urinates urinates you know underneath
i saw that i think at the end of the day
i think it's a good talking point
especially for your own team oh hunter
did this why did you look that up
all right let's i just don't think it
moves the needle okay coca-cola lost
four billion dollars in a market value
after soccer
star cristiano ronaldo suggested people
drink
water is what he said okay so the soccer
supervisor christina ritallo gestures at
euro 2020 press conference on monday
wiped four billion dollars off of
coca-cola's market value ronaldo's ahead
of his team's match by the way this is
all he did
he literally just went like this no no
coca-cola
drink water that's all he did yeah he
didn't do anything i think
it's like less than 10 seconds right he
looked at it
just moved it right okay ronaldo ahead
of his team's match against hungary
irritably set aside two bottles of coke
then picked up a bottle of water and
said
agua the portuguese ward for water
coca-cola shares had fallen 1.6
by the end of the press conference its
market value dropped 4 billion to 238
from 242 coca-cola an official sponsor
the uefa
euro 2020 tournament reportedly said in
a statement that everyone is entitled to
drink their preferences
and has deferring tastes and needs
ronaldo has previously expressed
disapproval of coca-cola and other
unhealthy foods and beverages
his fitness routine is said to involve
eating six meals and taking five naps in
a typical
day what a day awesome that's a great
schedule so
the power of ronaldo yeah how powerful
is this what i think
it just talks about the power of the
personal brand
the ronaldo's of the world or the
messies of the world or the lebrons of
the world
or even the jake pauls of the world all
eyes are on them
and if they do something it could move
markets and in this case ronaldo moved
the market by four billion dollars
in 10 seconds basically saying he's not
a coke guy so
you know who would be very proud of him
adam sandler and the water boy would be
very proud
bobby boucher would be very proud of
ronaldo right now
i i think this is a little overplayed i
you know
basically do you think 4 billion is
overplayed okay
what is coke worth 242
now 238 correct that's exactly right and
their high for the year was 257.
the stock's at 54 right now give or take
the low for the year is 43 the high for
the year is 56.57
so basically you have a little blip that
could have been any given day
coke could have moved four billion
dollars just with market factors the
price of sugar things like this but i
think what's
it's interesting we're pointing out is
how
markets can move with influencers and i
think that's a story the story isn't
coke lost 4 billion and they're going to
get it back
and coke is not just all about soda
they've been buying into
other drinks they own minute maid you
know they have dasani
they've been going not full bore on soda
for a while and they've been taking
caffeine out of
sodas they've been taking sugar out of
sodas they've been trying to follow that
you mean
they they caught more heat for vending
machines on campuses
with um economically priced you and i go
down to a vending machine a lobby of a
building it's a dollar dollar 50 for a
coke
but they were vending machines at 50
cents so the kids could get cokes with
their
lunches and they're pointing out there's
a lot of sugar in that there's probably
something else you want
you know you know adolescent developing
kids to be having before they go back in
the classroom
and so the story here is that
influencers now
really move markets that's the headline
not that koch lost four billion in one
day that they're going to get back
in the next another sidebar here
how are the influencer now i agree um
i think uh something just this might be
a good little case study
on inflation and uh like a can of coke
used to be 50 cents now it's a dollar
fifty and now they're
now they're keeping the price the same
size uh but they're about the same price
but they're basically
making the cans smaller have you noticed
these smaller coke cans
uh it's just it's just interesting that
they're all sort of around the same
price but
the sizes are getting smaller now the
greater the greater headline
you know if i was at forbes or some
place my headline you know what my
headline would have been on this
what's that and it says you know
influencer marketing confirmed
as coke stock moves when cristiano
ronaldo
you know touches two bottles in us in a
certain way and it's for everyone that
says
gosh why do you pay the kardashians for
a tweet you know fifty thousand dollars
for a tweet and then a backup tweet and
a retweet
it's 50 000 here's your package here's
your rate card why do they pay
instagram influencers this why is all
this happening the reason it's happening
because
influencers move markets and make
products
move that's the story here okay
i think the story here is that he takes
five naps a day that's pretty gangster
that's
uh i think everybody would want that but
i mean
he's killing it by the way simple as
that yeah he's killing it he does one ad
he gets nine million views i mean people
are paying them left and right to just
do ads this guy's making so
much money it's not even funny i mean
look is there this guy's
uh where's he on your list of like just
the
the most alpha males out there studs
soccer player best of all time he's a
total good looking
where is he
he's up there sam sam how many balloon
doors
has uh cristiano ronaldo won
i don't know the answer
uh i don't think it's nine or ten i
think it was three or four i thought he
and messi
won like eight of the last ten or
something was that like a trick question
what are we trying to do right there no
no no that's fine
he's got five just so that's that's like
that's like the mvp
of the world of soccer it's five and so
he's not just an alpha male
this guy's a tiger we can't hear you
just so you know you're muted we can't
hear you
yeah go ahead he has his own museum
it's beautiful but what he has done also
in business
yeah but the question is does he have
the statue that uh
uh james corden made for
beckham because the staff i mean beckham
has the greatest statue of all time i
don't know if you guys seen that much of
chin have you seen the
pull this up guy the ugly statue where
yeah yeah
pull up pull up the statue with david
beckham's statue james corden you guys
never seen this before it's hilarious
he pulled a trick on him he says so the
day the opening of the statue
gordon brings him out to say you guys
have to see the spoof just go to images
because you can't play the video
uh uh he does he makes this statue
and he says uh brings him out he says
look we're so excited about it look at
his arms how long it is the fake one
hilarious fake statue look at that
arms are long he says and and the artist
who is
uh the comedian who is acting like the
artist is mars gibrani
and he's going talking to him say we
spent some because your arms are long we
wanted to give you a
width because you have so much power on
your chin you have such a powerful
chin he says i don't have a chin that
big now go on the butt side
go in the back go in the back go butt
type in butt
great hair type and butt okay let's just
see if they show it or not
there's he says i don't have a butt that
big
he says you have a perfect butt so we
wanted to really highlight how big
yeah he's thick t-h-i-c-c
see i don't think ronaldo has a statue
like that but ronaldo is a legend and
when he does sponsorships people make
that comes
quick quick shout out to um quick shout
out to clay smith whose
great grandma just passed away she had
17 grand
great grandkids and uh you know want to
give a shout out to
clay smith's great grandma who just
passed away that's his statue and by the
way what's this
that has got to be that has got to be
that's got to be the worst statue i've
ever seen in my life i would be so
offended if i was saying
ronaldo before and after it looks like
like two sides have been put together
before and after what are you talking
about braces or which one yeah it's like
if you put your hand over each side of
the statue right now did i click on the
first one
you're saying he wasn't good looking at
one point i'm just saying you know
everyone has to go through an ugly phase
even ronaldo was kind of
go go down kai go down the red shirt
right there boom
yeah i mean you know clearly he's
looking better these days
so can we see your before and after
is there a picture of you i'm not trying
to compete with ronaldo but
homie's done well for himself
all of your 19 female that were
following you the ladies that were
following
they left out right because you're so
offended you offended the uh
ronaldo right okay trump let's talk
about trump let's talk about trump here
donald trump set to visit border before
kamala here's newsweek story
donald trump has increased pressure on
vice president kamala harris as he
announces he will visit the u.s mexico
border before late june trump who made
building
a wall to combat immigration one of his
key presidential campaign promises said
he would visit our nations down
decimated a southern border with texas
governor greg abbott on june 30th biden
is also for
facing criticism for the record levels
of my immigrant migrants
attempting to enter the country
illegally since his uh time in office
after walking back some of trump's more
hard-line immigration policies in an
attempt to provide a more humane
approach in april nearly 179
000 people were detained trying to enter
the border the highest level since april
of last year abbott
sent a letter to biden in late march
demanding answers to the humanitarian
crisis at the border abbott said he
plans to build his own wall
along the state's border with mexico
although it is unclear
if he has the resources funds or
authority to do so adam i'm going to go
to you first
what do you think about the story here i
i got to tell you this the the
everything with the board are so
politicized and i don't have the answers
here i don't think anyone does that's
the biggest problem here
i will say that you know i i'm a big fan
of pop culture did you see the
trending video that was going on with
kamala harris and donald trump this
weekend no
all right well if you've got kids in the
room use your earmuffs uh
it was really actually hilarious so i've
never been to europe either yeah
the um kamala harris came out
this was the video kamala harris being
basically saying
if you're in mexico don't come
do nothing don't come and then it cuts
it donald trump goes
i'm gonna come
it actually doesn't go like that it
doesn't say mexico you're right
she just said she just says don't come
exactly don't come exactly he says
oh i'm gonna come it's just it's like
that's genius marketing right it is
genius
so clearly you clearly have strong
opinions about this trump's coming
kamala
encourages him not to come he's coming
anyway that's a that's a brash man right
there all right all right all right
talking no you're not allowed to
have fun on biz doc time it's time to
get down to this it's about to cancel
y'all
do not handle me biz doc go ahead listen
catman
this is all about the narrative right
what was the narrative
they wanted to get him out of office
they wanted him defeated
the reelection so the whole narrative on
immigration was you're putting kids in
cages you're not letting people come
here they just want freedom here
and keep the borders open so whatever
trump was trying to do they were trying
to do the opposite and they were
spinning it for the purpose of
voting blocks okay that's what that was
the narrative
now it goes the other way the other way
is now
biden's in office trump is gone and
you've got arizona
and texas and the city of austin and
remember
there's a lot of californians that are
in austin there's a big thing down there
all these billboards and t-shirts you
can get keep austin weird
mean weirder than the rest of texas
meaning more lavender than blue
or red the narrative is now
hey we have some really real problems
here need to be cleaned up we got
problems here
san francisco does not like national
news stories talking about
feces urine syringes and homelessness
they don't like it
and there are people there that want to
see it fixed and now it's a different
side of the narrative
the narrative when you're getting trump
out is is
the whole problem at the border is about
trump and give these people freedom
now the vice president is going down
there saying
do not come here don't stop i'm gonna do
the whole thing she's saying
don't come across this is a bigger
problem we won't know why they're
leaving their country
what did trump say stop
the point they're flipping the narrative
and
it is so cruel to the american voter it
is so
cruel to the people that you're supposed
to be serving that are living in these
communities where these secondary
problems are happening
because there's nowhere for these folks
to go if they were joining up with
relatives they were finding a job they
had things going
then give us your tired reporter huddled
masses yearning to briefly come across
so what's your solution be
solution-oriented identifying the
problem what's my damn solution my
solution
is that there are america is not a race
america is a melting pot and experiment
of people that came from somewhere
and have a door at the border welcome
people that are refugees but there's a
process to do it you can't have them
streaming across
a beautiful door and one one moment
you've got people
just all over the border issue and just
ignoring all the secondary issues
because they just want to get trump out
of office
and now they're willing to look at some
of these these problems
and it's like they're going the other
way it's the hypocrisy of this
is just stifling let me ask you you ever
lived in a gated community
uh well would a high rise be considered
a gated community
you lived with millionaires and decca
millionaires where you lived there was a
lot of rich people in that building
that's true that's that that's called
the gated community yeah right there was
a lot of security when people came here
how'd you like that it's nice it's nice
right
okay i do as well i think america's got
to become a gated community
because where do people typically want
to go to
the fanciest places what's the fanciest
country in the world
still today where you lived
is a pretty fancy place it's a beautiful
place right
it was gated i think it's nothing
nothing wrong with
america being gated as well to protect
itself especially people who are living
down there here's the other part i'll
tell you about this
um dude do you think two years ago go
ahead
no do you think we need a gate on both
sides uh not on canada's side okay you
know why
you know why because canadian government
is actually doing a decent job keeping
their people there
mm-hmm and canadian are not trying to
break the law to come down here we don't
have a canadian border problem
we have a central america problems not
just mexico salvadorans are going
through guatemala
to make it it's a south and central
america problem not a canada problem
that we have
a border prime i mean nobody from europe
is swimming out here it's a long swim so
it's going to be we don't need to put a
border between there because the sharks
are going to handle that
themselves we don't need to worry about
that we've got great security in the
atlantic ocean canadians are some of the
greatest people in the world
they are except for any one of them in
this room they got some issues everybody
else i would say yes now let's talk
about this now
canadians are very good and they know
how to drink a lot of beer by the way
kokanee so here's a
here's a part about this here so for me
it's very simple
when we started our youtube channel and
then we changed the channel to
valuetainment
and we started doing a couple interviews
and i started liking doing interviews
because i enjoy people's stories i like
talking to people
a lot of the people that were doing
interviews at the time they would only
interview people that came to their show
it's like no you don't come to me i'm
not doing the interview i told my guys
here's what we're going to be doing we
will go to them okay
and here's what i want you to do when i
go to cities to do an interview i want
you to set me up with three
if there's three interviews in a city
i'll go so my booker had one job they're
gonna put three interviews in a city
yeah
i'm going so i'd go to new york time
remember is my schedule let me tell you
it's not easy
because you have to remember the notes
the facts all that stuff and the
question so you're sitting down one
minute from
you know a general uh who was a general
that we interviewed in new york
uh mcchrystal and then i'm sitting with
the scaramucci then i'm sitting with
bernard carrick then i'm sitting with it
was back it was ariana huffington then
i'm sitting with you back to back to
back to back to back then you got to get
ready for the questions you're asking
right okay
but we went to the guests because we
were a small youtube channel we only had
50 000 subs
80 000 subs 100 000 subs so we went to
them what happened eventually
eventually we got a half a million subs
a million subs couple million subs three
million subs
now people are willing to come over here
why because we now earn the right but
even today
yesterday i flew out to do an interview
with one of the most powerful attorneys
in the world that many know but i'll
you know very soon i'll talk about who i
was with yesterday
a two-hour interview ended up being six
hours at his place that we were with and
talking about stories and seeing stuff
that it's just private stuff that we
talked about
which will you know we'll share with the
world here soon who the person was that
i interviewed
moral the story is this anybody that i
ever met
who kept crushing it they always went to
the problem
they always went to the source they
always went to the customer
goldman sachs they're having a
conversation with the other investment
bankers
you know what the biggest complaint was
here's what the biggest complaint was
why some investment bankers were losing
business to goldman sachs i can't
believe i'm playing with a mango right
now
he says the reason why we're losing
business to goldman sachs is because
goldman sachs investment bankers still
get on the plane and go meet with the
client to be
their money backers they still are
willing to go meet with them
while everybody else is just doing zoom
zoom zoom zoom zoom
goldman said we're going to come and
meet with you guess what happened during
covet
they got the big money the other guys
are like don't leave your office sit
right
there god forbid something were to
happen goldman got the business
very simple that's why they weren't
careful they weren't careless they were
killed they weren't careful
but they got the business by the way
they were my guys so they they wanted to
recover that a couple months ago
they go to you is what they do okay my
sales guys i have a guy
in the company uh uh sheena mats apollo
you've met them before
we paid them nearly 300 last month okay
is what they made okay
month you know in a month you know what
you know what they're very good at i
have
many guys that were bigger than when we
were coming up and i would tell them
go meet the clients and they would say
no why would i go they need to come to
me i don't drive two hours i don't drive
three hours
what does sheena matsupala do they'll
fly to memphis
they'll fly to seattle they'll fly to
new york they'll fly to
baltimore they'll fly to orlando they'll
fly to san diego
they'll fly to arizona they go to people
they didn't make the money last month by
luck they made it because they went
to the source to the customer they went
there right okay
um trump is doing
what they should be doing he's going
where the problem is and by the way
here's what's a very bad look for them
right now
everybody in america lester holt is
asking kamala harris why are you not
going to the border
the former president whom you kicked out
whom you silenced on all of social media
platforms said
don't worry i'm going to go over there
and i'm going to go with greg greg
abbott and we're going to go see what's
going on
and try to help and influence and give
support to the people that are working
on the border because you're not going
to ever know what they do at the border
until you go see what they're going to
do at the border
there's a big difference between you
seeing it on a video there's a big
difference between you reading an
article about it
there's a big difference between me
sending you to go to the border versus i
go to the border there's a very very big
difference for you to see it
you gain loyalty that way years ago one
of the best leadership books i ever read
was by donald t phillips called lincoln
on leadership
you know what lincoln on leadership said
he said circulate
amongst your troops it's what made
lincoln
so admired by the people that work with
them he went and circulated
amongst his troops he would say how you
doing private how are you doing
specialist
how you doing corporal how are things
everything good
how we looking circulate amongst your
troops if you ever seen a movie lincoln
played by daniel day-lewis you'll see
where he's sitting he's sitting amongst
the troops it's why they call him
the greatest president of all time
because he went
and circulated amongst the troops he
didn't sit back and order others what to
do
he went and circulated amongst the
troops
and that's all 45 is doing right now
something 46
can learn something from and take some
notes and say you know what
maybe we ought to go out there because
we're looking at fools right now that
the former president
needs to go out and we're not even going
there and the number one issue one of
the biggest issues we're facing right
now in america is what
immigration because we made people in
south and central america think
it's open borders come on down it's not
a good look for the current
administration
and all i can tell you is trump
capitalized on an opportunity and it
looks very good for him for 2024.
not saying he's going to run or not it's
a very good look for him because it
shows republicans care more about the
border
than democrats do historically democrats
have always been known what
they care more about those coming across
the border more than anybody else's does
but they're not going there if
republicans win that
statement which is what republicans care
more about the border than others
is that a small percentage could that be
a half a point could that be one point
could that be a quarter of a point could
that be a point and a half
it could be does the point and a half
mean anything in midterms
does a point mean anything in midterms i
mean trump just announced he's going on
a
tour across the country with what bill
o'reilly to go and do what to
talk and you know address issues and
answer cool questions and he's going out
there working as a
president that's just not sitting there
saying i'ma go out there circulate
amongst the troops
look anybody whether it's your
competitors
anybody in politics and business and
sports anybody that does that you better
tip your hat off to them and say listen
i got respect for this guys because he
wants to play ball
and that percent and a half by the way
takes a lot of work and energy to do
that
a lot of work and energy to do that
that's why many don't want to do it it's
fine you just said percent and a half
and just remember a percent and a half
is a three-point swing right the net
difference is three
that's the whole ball game on the last
four presidential elections
that's the ball game so
you you you move the populace something
like that yep
on a on a lightning rod issue like this
it's
it it's defining and then the
other guy is now making the policies
it's so funny people look at
you're so right about things you're
saying today you know people
if let me put it this way if you're
watching a weatherman by the way this is
not a left or right thing george bush
senior has become so much above
like i'm above everybody else i'm the
former director of cia i have more
experience in politics than anybody else
and the lady from our
the lady asks her quote ask him the
question about debt how does the
national debt affect your family and
says what you don't think i'm affected
by the debt
and then bill clinton comes and says
ma'am can you please tell me how it's
affecting your life
and a lady answered questions you know
what in the state of arkansas here's
what i do
what we've done in our state is we
understand what it is to go through this
and i understand your feelings and if
you vote me as your president i will be
able to
data it's the economy stupid bill
clinton equals donald trump in this
situation
circulating amongst troops absolutely
they relate to the average price
why do you think um comma some this has
to be a strategy of some
something like i'm not a big fan of
negative attention yeah why would you
get attention if she doesn't go
if she goes so that's the reason that
they're saying look kamala don't go
because if you do go it's going to be a
lot of negative attention is at the
border with the board is a mess
it's like bad pr so they're making a
conscious decision
i'm going to step back because her
response was i've never been to europe
which was i think was
ridiculous but okay there must be a
reason she's let's
just say you got your you always hide
your brother away from your girl
for whatever reason okay and then you go
and you
your girl meets your brother and all she
talks about on the drive
back from dinner is your brother and
you're like dude you're with me why are
you talking about my brother
and she says you know what i like your
brother he's so funny
i like him so much that story he said oh
my gosh and you're just like
ah i can't believe he's talking about
this i don't want to bring attention to
it right this is
the level of insecurity everybody has a
level of insecurity this is purely an
insecurity thing
if they go to the border it's going to
show that trump's policies did better on
the border than theirs
that is not going to help them for the
next two years so you cannot bring
attention in an area where trump won
so that is a strategic move brilliant it
is a strategic move but it's not a
brilliant strategic move
it backfires it gives an opening to
trump what they have to do is the
following this would have been a better
move on them my suggestion
could be wrong i'm just an entrepreneur
they could have gone there
together and they could have said here's
what's happening
here's the issue here's what we have to
do about it we're working on it right
now we have our team over there and i
went for myself to see it
this is what we're doing right this is
what we're not doing right this is what
we're going to get to the bottom of give
us 90 days
that's the better approach and the
american people you know what they would
have said okay cool all right let's move
on
you know the whole thing about the the
i'm sorry where you go out there and you
say
sorry and then people move on like okay
cool that's that's cool i appreciate no
problem and just kind of move on
people forget sometimes people just want
to know they're putting paying the
putting the right attention to the issue
that matters to them they're not doing
it with this you know what have been a
boss move what if you do
a bipartisan group that goes down
together it's not going to happen that's
my point
is that there's so both sides presidents
are the most divisive presidents both
sides in a long time like at the end of
the day do you want to fix the issues or
do you want to play politics if you
actually want to fix the issue
you bring a kamala who goes with greg
abbott you bring a beta o'rourke and you
bring
uh representatives from arizona texas
from both sides and you actually figure
it out but no they want to play politics
both sides are guilty both obama and
trump
did this they both did it where was
getting away from the center that we win
when we go more to the center i love
i love what bill bill maher is doing
right now
i love what stewart is doing right now i
love what russell brand is doing right
now
i love what tucker's doing right now i
love what a lot of these guys are doing
right now where they're calling out both
sides you need more of that a little bit
of hannity is
hannity trump can't do nothing wrong in
hannity's eyes but trump can do a lot
wrong
in tucker's eyes you need some of that
today and it's bringing us more to the
center
more unifying less dividing center we
can have different differing opinions
but we got to be more in the center to
understand by the way somebody commented
here and they said
uh uh uh career ships uh said
completely agree with pbd it's easy to
get up and go to where the top people
are that's why i'm flying out to from uk
to florida to cppd
tom adam and the vault in september see
you there richard ed richard we're
seeing
looking forward to seeing you that i do
conference twice once a year and it's
called the vault conference the last one
we did it was 2019
and people from 40 plus countries showed
up it was only 500 people this one we're
doing this year at the diplomat we're
expecting 3 000 people to show up
from 100 plus different countries and
the speakers we're about to announce
they're very strategic speakers that
we're gonna have at this event
and it's gonna be investors founders uh
entrepreneurs c-suite executive sales
people employees who want to grow their
business and those that are trying to
raise their money
this is not an event i would miss if i
were you especially after
us going through covet you're going to
want to find out strategies that are
working for people
postcode there's going to be a lot
there's a lot of money being made right
now because people simply have better
strategies than you and if you're not
yet
registered and you want to go with us go
to i think the the website is what deval
conference dot com can you put it up bro
put the uh matter of fact go to the
website thevaultconference.com to show
it
uh we we want to see all of you if
you're not in this is going down what
early september what are the first
week of september september 1st
and then we're doing some unique things
at the end we're going to get a yacht
and we're going to go out the
diplomat is a beautiful property it'll
be two and a half days of training
you'll get that manual that we have
there and the
ticket tickets go to the bottom there'll
be general seating
uh general seats platinum executive
founder ceo i think ceo's fully sold out
it says
i think it's one or two laps one or two
left that's about to be sold out so you
can't buy that ticket
founder is about to be sold out you can
only buy the general platinum and
executive tickets
uh uh and i definitely look forward to
seeing many of you guys by the way the
people that want to come visit the south
florida it's actually a
cheaper time of year to come a you can
fly into fort lauderdale or miami to get
to this location
and i got i guess right now we got to
give a quick shout out to
to the team that's putting this together
sales guys leo
my guy don donnie brasco they're doing a
great job i got to give them respect
they're doing a great job they're all
about okay having said that gang i
daryl i think we're doing podcast next
week monday
instead of tuesday so we're going to be
doing podcasts on monday next week
not on tuesday so put it on your
calendar monday nine o'clock
uh sunville or is it same time nine
o'clock okay monday nine o'clock not
tuesday we will do it again next monday
nine o'clock have a wonderful weekend
everybody go bucs take care bye bye
you